there's a power inside of me something I
don't understand
shall we begin sometimes it comes out
[Applause]
where did you say you were from again I
didn't
[Music]
Tigers have always been my favorite ever
since I was a kid you have to be naked
[Music]
so can't believe you traded in the horse
for a mini man I really like to be back
know
[Music]
my mom says there's no such thing as
monsters I think she's wrong when I feel
that darkness come out it feels good
it was a hero to me live with Bruce
Wayne is gonna change your life ever I
admired him at first the police they
believe it may not have been an accident
but I had to walk away I was becoming
too much like him
[Music]
you
wore everything led me here to you
you're the boy from the circus
[Music]
please can you help me
[Music]
[ __ ] that
there's something people inside of me
you're scared again but you can control
her
I don't know what has become
[Music]
sometimes when I feel the darkness
it feels cut
[Music]
my mom says there's no such thing as
monsters I used to think that I was
wrong
you